I'm going to leave it at nine hundred
ninety dollars because we're going to do
something with this to show you what we
want to do that's new I want you to come
down here to the bottom left hand corner
okay and you should seek here it might
have got names but yours might say sheet
1 sheet 2 g-3 do you see that yeah so
each of these things you're looking at
is called a sheet right they're called
spreadsheets because literally they're
like big piece of paper and you'd get a
big table and you would spread it out so
you can see all done okay so what I want
you do is I want you to hit this new
sheet icon it's like a little rectangle
and it's got like an orange star on okay
and that will give you surprise surprise
a blank sheet okay it should look like
that all right give me a sec I just want
to make all of my fonts a bit bigger
first okay so here's what we're going to
do now make this a bit bigger right
here's the information that we've got
we've earned all this money suppose you
change your mind you're like oh I don't
know I really want that phone but just
can't justify putting down that amount
of money all in one fit and say goodbye
to mayo or my hard-earned pay okay so
instead of buying something instead of
splurging we're going to save how
risk-averse of you okay so on this new
sheet right what we'll do is let's work
out what happens if for a number of
years okay we put in and we make savings
okay and savings can interest for us
okay so I under this some under this
column here i'm going to say well if i
start off so this is 0 this is no time
has passed what money am i going to
start with okay so i could write down
999 okay but we've got spreadsheets here
don't write down numbers if the
calculator can write down numbers for
you okay so I've written it equals okay
while that's still active it I want you
to go back to your first sheet go back
and i want you to click on that 909
dollars that total pay right and you can
see it's flashing right
so then you press enter ok so now these
sheets can talk to each other which is
really cool so whatever um this amount
of money is right that's going to be our
first hour starting balance if you like
ok so you can see if I am what did we
say before $25 you said $25 before I ya
know you said 20 dinchu someone else
said 25 so if i if i change that to 25
ok so now this number is changed and if
i come over to my new sheet it's
responded ok so i'll undo that let's all
start with the same 999 I'll come and
have a look in a second I see all right
now I could go and type 1 2 3 4 that's a
bit boring though ok so instead i'm
going to say i want to go plus one plus
one plus one how do i do this to
remember how we did it good good so you
start an equation right you you press up
to select the cell right above you ok
and then you say plus one ok so if i do
that and now if I copy it all the way
down as long as I like and if I pasted
them all in I've got all the values
there that ok looking good so you've got
all those numbers going down you can go
as far as you like I've gone to 20
something but it doesn't matter you can
add more if you need it okay okay so
someone tell me what's an interest rate
does anyone got a bank account knows
what the interest rate is ok let's see
rates and fees there we go bank account
every day what are you guys you guys are
still swears a student one you'd say but
that sounds about right yeah
okay here we go wow that's really lame
that's really low okay let's go with
that anyway 3.6 four percent that all
right just sound reasonable to you guys
Wow look at that point zero one percent
that's like nothing wow that's really
say okay I'm going to go with 3.64 is
that ok 3.64 okay come back to your
spreadsheet well you're probably still
on it up here in the corner i'm going to
say interest rate and i'm going to call
3.6 four percent and i'm just going to
put that there so that i can refer to it
okay alright so I've got an interest
rate I've got an amount of money so
think back to when we were doing
investing okay how do I work out how
much is in that bank account after a
year I'll give you a free him it starts
with an equals okay I could add some
things couldn't i right i could add this
to something else but what am I attitude
I don't want to just add 3.64 I want it
like a dollar sign right so I reckon
it's actually going to be a better
suggestion to take that number and think
back to how you worked out compound
interest their compound interest okay
hold on hold on hold on it starts with
them you I think someone say simple
interest I want compound interest yet
hold on hold on I can hear 1 plus R in
brackets I've got missing bits and I'm
missing something still good okay there
we go they go there we go it's just a
cacophony of people okay fine they go
right so what are the pieces here right
p stands for principle which in this
case is that neither draenei odhav now i
could write 999 but instead i'm just
going to say be too because that's
that's the amount okay so i'm going to
put in be too okay now nestled in here
this is actually this times this right
now what was that symbol in a
spreadsheet for multiplication is the
asterisk right ok so it's so far so good
and then you've got a 1 plus now the
rain right now we've written down 3.6
four percent but in here yeah we need a
decimal domi so the 0.036 form I guess
those are the numbers we've got okay
yeah okay I'm going to get to that one
in a second okay we'll just start with
this for now and just will all be
consistent okay that's a very good
question there ok now we would have to
put a number up here right for how much
I how long it's been in there and
therefore what it should be so it's time
right it's going to be one but then it's
going to be two and then it's gonna be
three and four to five does that make
sense so I should really be using these
numbers over here shouldn't I um we're
raising to a power what's our symbol for
power it's a funny one right yeah it's a
damn it's that little hat thing which is
above the six and then what I want is
this cell over here you can look at the
coordinates you can see what should I
put in there that'll be it will be three
but I think it's in this a coin yeah
that's right that's okay that's why
we're doing this right okay they go
right let's try this out let's give it a
spin okay so equals okay I already got
the beach to in their times pop your
bracket in 1 plus and then hit is the
interest rate that looks like so far so
good close the brackets raise the power
and now if I I have two choices i can
either just click on this cell or i can
type in a three either way you'll get
the same result all right BAM now let's
let's change that formatting sense or
money there we go so does that look like
it's reasonable does that does that
sound about right I your I'm on I'm on
this 3.6 four percent business though so
this is this is a different interest
rate yeah yeah so this is a different
together now I guess it will depend on
how much money you actually have in the
bank account that number there okay now
how do I work out what's going to happen
next yeah so the great thing is we put
all this work into doing this formula
right but the formula should keep
working as I go down let's try to copy
paste stop does that seem like a
reasonable so number that seem in the
right ballpark i think it does and you
can keep going down right BAM they go
okay you can scroll down and you can see
what's happening what my cells are too
small Wow we've got millions of dollars
that's amazing okay not bad for three
point six four percent okay now I'll
teach you another trick okay can you see
how I've scroll further down right so
I've lost all of the titles that have I
popped on the top of my columns okay so
there are my arm there are my headings
okay so i'll teach you a trick go to the
top right be right at the top of your
spreadsheet okay and you know how he
said look there's the Home tab we were
lucky around with the data tab I want
you to go over to the view tats right at
the end view so under view what I want
this some see this top bit this top row
I wanted to always be there no matter
how far I scroll okay so Excel calls
these things pains so as in like window
panes so in the middle here it says
freeze panes so it starts to open up a
window you should that and you can see
it's got a nice preset option there for
ten our fries top row keep this top row
visible or scrolling through so i'll hit
that and then when i scroll ten-hour it
stays put okay so that's kind of useful
especially when you've got lots of lots
information you want to go further down
but you still want to know what
everything is talking about okay all
right now i'm curious we put this on
money in the baby hair right now and you
can see it increases but it starts
increase really really fast how fast how
would you work out in here how much
you're earning every single year like
how much some extra interest you're
getting okay I suppose if you're a bit
of a chop you could you know go to a
formula like that but we've got a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet can do this
for us right so for instance if I asked
you just one question how much was
earned in the first year how much
interest what would you do what would
you actually write so we can we can do
this amount right so i can go 10 35 36
minus 999 right which does sound
something like 36 ish dollars right both
but this is a spreadsheet come on we
don't need to do the numbers it'll do
the numbers for us what are the cells
that these numbers are in this is a this
is B 3 right that's be three and I
should take away want you to take away
bb2 good okay so i'm going to pop that
right there i'm gonna say equals B 3
minus b2 and you can see it colors the
writing and the cells to tell you it
knows what you're talking about and you
can enter and do you get there 36 ish
dollars that we were expecting okay but
the great thing is this is a formula so
you can copy that guy and then you can
just say well let's just keep on going
and see what happens and I go all the
way to 27 well it's too big I another
figure there we go okay so have a look
the first year you earn a pitiful
thirty-six dollars that's not even
enough to take your parents up do not
okay but then if you wait if you pay
[ __ ] not if not if you get one of those
fancy building very bag of things
they're expensive man so if you wait
another year right you're earning more
money and then more money and
money now hold on does this make sense
does it make sense that you would be a
millionaire bye-bye here they got your
millionaire just by sitting on that one
thousand dollars and doing nothing it
does seem too good to be true doesn't it
so my question is what's gone wrong so
you so we got two incidences you can go
do an experiment if you like I'll see
you in 20 years or we could think about
the mass of what's going on now I I know
what the answer is cuz I've designed
this spreadsheet but I wonder if you can
work out what's happening I'll give you
two or three minutes to try and look at
what's going on and why it's going wrong
okay if you think you have an answer
i'll come over to you test out your
hypothesis but for the rest of you i
want you to have a deep